vitaliser sont des non vaccinés ou des
vacciner à temps de comorbidité le délai
de la dose de rappel parce qu'ils
avaient passé de six à cinq mois en
décembre et de nouveau réduit trois mois
il faudra trois mois un de nouveau entre
entre chaque dose de rappel conformément
à l'avis de la haute autorité de santé
pas de surcharge hospitalière à ce stade
mais la propagation de microbes doit
interpeller et amplifier les mesures
pour éviter la désorganisation de notre
économie a fait savoir jean castex les
principales mesures annoncées ce soir
les grands rassemblements sont elles
limitées à une jauge de 2000 personnes
en intérieur à 5000 en extérieur la
consommation des boissons et de
nourriture dans les cinémas théâtres et
dans les enceintes sportives sont
interdites pour les trois prochaines
semaines la consommation dans les bars
et cafés autorisé seulement en position
assise pas de couvre-feu au 31 décembre
un comme ça a été suggérée dans hier ou
avant-hier par contre le premier
ministre appelle les français à la plus
grande vigilance il les a invités à
éviter toute toute forme de jeans et de
grandes fêtes de grand dîner il a
également invité les français à porter
le masque lors de cette soirée est de
maintenir les gestes barrière le recours
au télétravail sera obligatoire à partir
de au cours des trois prochaines
semaines trois jours par semaine au
minimum 4 si possible pas de report de
la rentrée scolaire les écoles seront
bel et bien ouverte lundi prochain alors
en ce qui concerne les nouvelles règles
d'isolement pour les personnes qu'à
contacter tout cas positifs elles seront
rendues d'ici la fin de la semaine mais
un retour un isolement de sept jours
contre dix sept jours actuellement avec
le variant omicron et envisager une
nouvelle évaluation de la situation
devrait avoir lieu la semaine prochaine
le 5 janvier an puisqu'un nouveau
conseil de défense sanitaire devrait
être organisée à ce moment là merci
beaucoup déjà des vagues en direct de
matignon viendra bien sûr vers vous plus
tard dans la soirée on va continuer bien
sûr à parler de cette conférence de
presse de jean castex et d'olivier
ferrand on va détailler bien entendu les
annonces faites ce soir on réagit
justement avec gilbert collard député
européen du rassemblement national et
franz à 4,9 délégué départemental du
modem ils sont tous les deux avec nous
sur rtl ans
bonsoir merci messieurs merci d'être
avec nous ce soir sur arte france alors
avant de rentrer dans les détails un des
mesures que l'on a entendu ce soir est
ce que le gouvernement se devait de
faire quelque chose alors que l'écart ne
cesse d'augmenter dans le pays on va
commencer avec vous à gilbert collard
consternant skull c'est la santé de tout
un peuple kaki en cause
depuis deux ans le gouvernement se
devait de faire quelque chose et
malheureusement depuis deux ans un
rapport sénatorial le deal indique c'est
triste mais c'est une réalité on a
supprimé des lits et l'hôpital a été
encore affaiblie aujourd'hui on entend
le gouvernement utiliser le mantra de la
vaccination je suis pas contre la
vaccination à je suis pas d'une
hostilité
maniable mais je retiens deux choses si
vous le permettez un sans vouloir
polémiquer puisque la question est trop
grave la première c'est que l'ancien
directeur général de la santé qui lui a
cette particularité
de ne plus être dans la boutique
vaccinale médicales pharmaceutiques
boutique est employé dans un sens qui
n'est pas péjoratif nous dit tout misé
sur le vaccin est dangereux vous
entendez l'ancien directeur général de
la santé qui est un homme devenu libre
je ne dis pas qu'ils l'étaient encore
quand il travaillait maintenant je pense
qu'il est devenu libre nous dicte tout
misé sur le vaccin est un danger et on a
on à l'institut pasteur qui nous dit que
la protection du vaccin et - de l'ordre
de 60% et en ce qui concerne l'argument
des fameuses formes graves sur lequel le
vaccin pourrait agir l'institut pasteur
nous dit que le vaccin devrait continuer
je cite à protéger contre les formes
graves il n'échappe à personne que c'est
le mode conditionnel qui est employé
donc le mode de l'incertitude le monde
le monde le mode du tout je pense très
sincèrement que
vouloir à tout prix à tout prix tout
misé sur le vaccin alors c'est un vaccin
qui ne vaccinent pas c'est une folie
maintenant c'est une folie dont je
n'arrive pas à comprendre la raison si
on a aussi rappelez vous quand même que
monsieur castex notre premier ministre
nous disait qu'avec
deux doses on peut pas être contaminé
et qu'aujourd'hui on vous dit tout le
contraire alors il faut trouver des
solutions et je pense que la pratique
des gestes barrières on aurait dû
maintenir le port du masque est par
exemple et on devrait généraliser le
port du masque ffp2 ce serait là une
bonne mesure mais alors vouloir
interdire les gens debout alors qu'il
paraît que on est moins contaminés quand
on est debout cas si tout cela me paraît
mais complètement aberrant
affolant inquiétant et quand je vois
arriver les élections qui se pointe je
suis très très très très préoccupés par
ce qui pourrait arriver un bond en
également le fait réagir également notre
autre guichet ce soir france 80 vous
avez également suivi un bien sûr les
annonces du premier ministre et
d'olivier ferrand le ministre de de la
santé gilbert collard parlais à
l'instant du tout miser sur sur la
vaccination c'est un peu ce que est ce
que fait le gouvernement qui a rappelé à
plusieurs reprises l'importance de la
vaccination et puis qui notamment
s'apprête à transformer le pass
sanitaire en passe vaccinale le tout
vacciner c'est ce qu'il faut faire pour
vous offrir quatre boeufs
alors tout d'abord comme le premier
ministre je commencerai par la fin c'est
à dire cette espèce de de menaces que
l'on fait peser sur les scrutins qui
doivent se tenir l'année prochaine le
premier ministre l'a rappelé il existe
un droit constitutionnel et ce droit
constitutionnel protège les élections
l'organisation des scrutins les scrutins
seront préparés il l'a dit en accord
avec les partis politiques
en accord avec le conseil
constitutionnel il n'y aura pas de coup
d'état il n'y aura pas de report des
élections nour pour en reparler si vous
le voulez dans quelques semaines ou
quelques mois mais ceux qui s'amusent à
faire peur et a crié à la dictature e
trompent les français comme ils trompent
les français
lorsqu'ils veulent tout à la fois
prétendre imposer l'eau masque
l'existence les confinements tout en
criant à la dictature à chaque fois qu
on confine le gouvernement a choisi quoi
qu'on en dise le juste milieu c'est à
dire oui on vaccine mais on protège
aussi par le masque en centre ville par
la distanciation sociale par des mesures
prudentielles il faut savoir s'adapter
ça fait deux ans que nous voyons que
nous entendons des mesdames soleil des
messieurs irma sur tous les plateaux de
télévision mais ils critiquent tout ce
que fait le gouvernement il ne propose
jamais rien alors il faut bien choisir
et le gouvernement a choisi l' équilibre
c'est pourquoi je pense qu'il a une
raison et qu'il a eu raison de ne pas
confiné et de ne pas nous enfermer pour
le 31 décembre tout en nous appelant à
la responsabilité
dernier point la liberté de culte à
laquelle nos concitoyens croyants sont
tellement attachés et j'en fais partie
et là aussi protéger de façon
constitutionnelle
nous restons un pays démocratique et
nous restons un pays que libertés
publiques
france 80 vous avez évoqué bien sûr la
campagne présidentielle qui qui
s'organisent en ce moment en france le
premier ministre l'a rappelé les jauges
elle et les annonces qui ont été faites
ce soir pourrait ne pas concerner les
meetings alors on rappelle que 2000
personnes maximum seront autorisés à
être à l'intérieur
dans l'est dans les salles de spectacle
est-ce que c'est pas un peu
contradictoire pour ceux qui nous
regardent de penser peut-être que plus
de personnes pourraient assister à des
meetings politiques gilbert collard
j'ai pourtant se demande je remercie
votre contradicteur d'avoir utilisé
cette image parce que quand on écoute
monsieur macro et notre monsieur k
secteur prévu en redemande qui est mal à
bien ouais et qui est monsieur soleil
levant c'est ubuesque pour employer un
mot qui est utilisé à longueur de temps
en effet c'est contradictoire c'est
comme autorisé
de monter dans les dents les dans les
métros
sansan vaccination avant c'est comme
autoriser les routiers à ne pas être
vaccinés tout cela est incompréhensible
mais j'en reviens à la question initiale
il s'agit pas personne ne parle de
dictature si si si vous avez peur il
faut il faut vous calmer je n'ai jamais
dit qu'on allait vers une dictature je
dis simplement que petit à petit et cela
devrait toucher tous les hommes les
femmes attachée au respect des libertés
parce que ça se grignote une liberté moi
je dis simplement que sous de la volonté
ou le prétexte chacun dira ce qu'il veut
de lutter contre la pandémie on peut pas
le nier nos libertés sont abîmés
détériorer en or la pratique des
libertés c'est une totalité quand on
commence à réduire une liberté on sait
pas jusqu'où peut aller son asphyxie
voilà mon inquiétude et quand je dis que
le gouvernement mise tout sur la
vaccination on sent rencontre ce soir
parce que des tonnes vaccins ont été
commandées recommandé et que ce serait
l'échec effroyable pour le président de
la république à quatre mois d'une
élection que de devoir dire
effectivement la vaccination n'est pas
la panacée
ce que monsieur castex disait il ya
quelques semaines ou quelques mois qu'on
ne pouvait pas être contaminé a appris
deux doses c'est encore vrai os
ça a été une faute une erreur pour ne
pas dire plus beaux et qu'aujourd'hui on
est dans la même incertitude ça serait
pour lui catastrophique de devoir
renoncer à l'argument du vaccin sur
lequel il a tant misé sur lequel l'union
européenne attend payer voilà maintenant
je ne dis pas moi qu'un jour ou l'autre
on n'aura pas peut-être une solution
parfaite mais pour l'instant lapin et
c'est très dangereux de faire croire
parce que ceux qui ceux qui veulent s'en
prennent une responsabilité terrible
parce qu'il ya des archives médiatique
est ce que vous dites en ce moment ses
archives et et si dans trois mois quatre
mois cinq mois 6 mois parce que tout se
sait tout apparaît on se rend compte que
on avait tout de suite mesuré
l'inefficacité du vaccin comme c'est dit
par de nombreux scientifiques et encore
il avant-hier par la tribune de genève
ça serait d'une responsabilité grave
grave et quand on voit ce que dit
l'institut pasteur quand on voit ce que
disent plein médecin on devrait être
beaucoup plus modérée et insister avant
la vie sur le port du masque par exemple
sur les gestes barrières est ce que vous
croyez en faisant comme moi j'ai vu des
gens qui étaient vaccinés arrivés vers
moi on s'embrasse je suis vacciné et
puis il ya eu aucune pédagogie de la
prudence qui accompagnait la vaccination
on a laissé croire tu en as laissé
croire aux gens qu'ils étaient à l'abri
or ce n'est pas vrai alors il faut
comprendre quand même que la population
a le droit de s'inquiéter et que vous et
moi qui avons des responsabilités on
doit faire en sorte de maintenir une
espèce d'équilibré entre les positions
des uns et des autres parce que la
vérité est probablement comme toujours
au milieu france 80 à ce que le
gouvernement comme le dit gilbert
collard a manqué parfois pendant cette
pandémie de pédagogie et de prudence
vous noterez une chose tout d'abord
c'est que mon contradicteur à 10 dans la
même phrase que nos libertés grignoter
mais qu'il fallait imposer le port du
masque ffp2 donc vous voyez que chacun
voit midi à sa porte
enfin c'est vrai que le pont vers la
mode ce n'est pas une atteinte aux
libertés
je préférais la main
nous avons pu varier dans le court
métrage
reviendra vers vous exactement de quoi
sera fait l'avenir et je pense et
j'espère qu'il y aura bientôt un
traitement un médicament qui fera
l'unanimité et qui permettra de guérir
des personnes atteintes du corps d'un
virus en attendant et bien il faut
cumuler seconde à ce qu'on a c'est le
masque c'est la distanciation sociale
c'est effectivement si possible vaccin
mais de ce point de vue je partage la
conviction de mon contradicteur c'est
vrai qu'il faut dire aux français que le
vaccin n'est pas la panacée qu'il faut
qu'il continue à se protéger à la fois
pour se protéger eux-mêmes pour protéger
les autres personnes vaccinées mais
aussi pour protéger les personnes qui ne
sont pas vaccinés et qui reste des
citoyens apparent à part entière et cela
je me tiens absolument effectivement à
le dire et gilbert collard le disait oui
le juste milieu vous connaissez la
phrase de françois bayrou in medio stat
virtus il est difficile de rester au
juste milieu parce que c'est c'est
courageux on s'en prend de chaque côté
de ceux qui prétendent toujours savoir
at avance mais à la fin il faut bien
tranché le gouvernement choisit je pense
un point d'équilibré
moi je pense que nous restons en
démocratie ce soir et je m'en réjouis
gilbert collard
'l'annonce principal un
qui a été dit dans cette conférence de
presse c'est bien sûr la transformation
du pass sanitaire en passe vaccinale le
gouvernement ne s'en cachent plus pour
pour se rendre dans les bars dans les
restaurants dans l'est dans les stades
dans les salles de concert terminé la
présentation d'un test négatif il faudra
absolument prouver que l'on a été
vaccinée votre sentiment très rapidement
j'aimerais vous entendre votre sentiment
à tous les deux avant de se terminer
nous reste plus vraiment que que
quelques minutes le ce qui prouve bien
que la vaccination dont mon
contradicteur vient de reconnaître
qu'elle n'était pas la panacée tout est
dit
est la seule solution maintenant il y en
a pas d'autre et là pour le coup
atteinte aux libertés elle existe porter
un masque c'est pas une atteinte à la
liberté ne pas pouvoir aller et venir
c'est une atteinte à la liberté ne pas
pouvoir se rendre dans un restaurant
pouvoir aller travailler c'est une
atteinte à la liberté ne pas pouvoir
prendre le train c'est une atteinte à la
liberté je ne comprends pas que vous ne
soyez pas la venue des libertés je ne
comprends pas que vous ne vous associez
pas ce que je dis pas ce que c'est bien
beau de citer le juste milieu mais il
faut pas non plus vouloir trop se
protéger dans cet empire du milieu il
faut parfois aussi reconnaître qu'il ya
des décisions extrêmes qui portent
atteinte à l équilibre des libertés est
regardée depuis le début franchement de
décision en décisions nos libertés elles
ont été entamées qui peut le nier mais
qui peut le nier et bientôt bientôt un
restaurateur pourra demander à vérifier
l'identité d'un citoyen et vous trouvez
que c'est normal
france 89 votre réaction quand à
l'arrivée bientôt du du pass vaccinale
en remplacement du pass sanitaires très
rapidement encore une fois car on a très
peu de temps la réaction très simplement
c'est que oui c'est une atteinte à la
liberté et j'espère qu'elle sera la plus
brève possible et je vous dis
franchement vous savez quand même moi je
suis un militant centriste s'il y a bien
des femmes et des hommes qui ont
toujours défendu la liberté ce sont les
militants centristes on les retrouvera
s'il le faut lorsqu'il faudra demander
que ce pass vaccinale se termine dès
qu'on pourra correctement soigner les
personnes atteintes du coronavirus et je
fais plus ponthieu confiance aux modérés
qu'aux personnes des extrêmes ou co
populiste pour défendre nos libertés
lorsqu'il s'agira de les recouvrer
intégralement nous serons là au modem
nous pouvons nous y engager nous sommes
le mouvement démocrate merci beaucoup
france quatre oeuvres dédiées
départemental du modem merci également à
vous gilbert collard député européen du
rassemblement national merci messieurs
d'avoir été avec nous et d'avoir réagi
elle ce soir aux annonces gouvernement
de nombreuses annonces donc on en parle
bien sûr avec notre reporter à nadège ad
razak devant matignon
à nazelles abderrazak bonsoir alors
encore une fois que retenir bien
évidemment de cette conférence de presse
d'olivier ferrand et de jean castex soir
la vaccination nous protège et protège
les autres a déclaré ce soir jean castex
le premier ministre celui là même qui
déclaré à la télévision il y a quelques
mois que deux doses de vaccin et bien
empêcher la contamination et la
transmission du virus il avait tort est
visiblement l'objectif actuel avec le
projet de loi du pass vaccinale et ce
sont les mots du premier ministre et de
faire peser la contrainte sur les
non-vaccinés eux qui sont les premiers
malades ducobu 19 hospitalisé selon ses
dires
dans tous les services de soins
critiques l'immense majorité des
personnes hospitalisées avec des formes
graves de l'aco vide ne sont pas
vaccinés ou n'ont pas de couverture
vaccinale complète j'ai parcourir la
france des services de réanimation pour
dire elle a sa ble ment au personnel mon
soutien et mon admiration et je peux
vous dire qu'il n'ya pas photo sur la
nature des hospitalisations et des
formes graves ce sont des personnes non
vaccinées ou des malades vacciner mais
atteint de comorbidités graves
l'élément que les décisif est et demeure
la vaccination voilà pourquoi comme je
voulais dit lors de ma précédente
intervention nous faisons tout pour
accélérer et renforcer la vaccination
le délai pour la dose de rappel qui a
été réduite de 6 à 5 mois en décembre à
2 nous vaud était a réduit il faudra
compter trois mois désormais entre les
différentes dose de rappel conformément
à l'avis de la haute autorité de santé
les principales mesures annoncées ce
soir par jean castex les grands
rassemblements sont limitées a plu à
2000 personnes en intérieur à 5000 à
l'extérieur la consommation des boissons
et de nourriture dans les cinémas
théâtres et enceintes sportives sont
interdites pour les trois prochaines
semaines le recours au télétravail est
rendue obligatoire dans toutes les
entreprises dans la mesure du possible
avec trois jours de télétravail au
minimum pas de couvre-feu pour le 31
décembre comme hypothèse a été posé sur
la table hier et bien la mesure n'a pas
été retenue le premier ministre a
toutefois appelé les français à la plus
grande vigilance à continuer à maintenir
les gestes barrières et si possible
porter le masque pas de retour
pas de report non plus de la rentrée
scolaire les écoles seront bel et bien
ouverte à partir de lundi prochain ce
qui concerne les nouvelles règles disent
elles manquent à contacter pour les
personnes qu'à contacter tout cas
positifs elle devrait être annoncé d'ici
la fin de la semaine mais on devrait
revenir logiquement à une durée
d'isolement de sept jours comme c'était
le cas avec les précédents variant et
plus de 17 jours comme c'est le cas
actuellement avec le variant au micro
d'olivier veyrat qui était aux côtés du
premier ministre ce soir a appelé les
français à se faire vacciner en masse
pour éviter les formes graves de la
maladie même si le variant omicron est
nettement moins dangereux que les
variants un précédent l'écoutent
omicron a cette capacité rare contaminé
des personnes qui ont déjà attrapé le
coc vide et même des personnes qui ont
eu des formes symptomatiques voir des
formes symptomatiques cder du coc vide
cette proportion a contaminé change
aussi la donne on peut donc retomber
malade si on attrape le au micro micro d
est moins sensible aux vaccins que le
variant delta mais c'est une bonne
nouvelle la troisième dose quand on
était à jour de son rappel fait
immédiatement remonter le niveau de
protection au dessus de 90 % même bien
au-dessus de 90 % face au risque de
formes graves les personnes à risque
restent donc les personnes non vaccinées
les personnes vaccinées mais qui sont
très fragiles parce qu'elles sont très
âgés ou parce qu'elles souffrent
d'immunodépression et puis les personnes
qui ont un schéma vaccinal qui n'est pas
complet c'est-à-dire les personnes qui
ont eu deux doses mais pas encore leur
troisième une vaccination complète
éloigne le risque de formes graves
éloigne le risque de réanimation même si
vous deviez contracté le virus
une nouvelle évaluation de la situation
devrait avoir lieu la semaine prochaine
puisque un nouveau conseil de défense
est prévu ce sera le 5 janvier prochain
si beaucoup nadège ad razak pour toutes
ces précisions des nouvelles mesures
donc nous allons les commenter avec
notre éditorialiste alexis poulain
alexis poulain bonsoir robot fois vous
avez bien sûr suire fille est avec nous
cette conférence de presse entre olivier
ferrand et et et jean castex l'une des
mesures un principal je le disais tout à
l'heure c'est la transformation du pass
sanitaire en passe vaccinale votre votre
regard là-dessus
là dessus c'était attendu puisque le
gouvernement avance tel un bulldozer par
décret pendant une période de vacances
pour aller plus vite prendre les
français par surprise j'avais avant
cette conférence promis des mesures
illisible je crois qu'on a été servi
après le lait les plages statique où il
fallait bouger sur la plage l'auto
attestation de sortie là on nous a sorti
du chapeau l'interdiction de consommer
de boue dans les bars alors je lève mon
verre à cette formidable mesure un toast
à la santé de jean castex et olivier
ferrand parce que c'est formidable d'un
côté on ne peut plus boire debout dans
les bars mais on ne peut plus boire à
sinon plus dans les cinémas ni manger de
pop corn ce sont deux grandes mesures
prises dans cette guerre contre le
coronavirus on peut voir que là on a mis
vraiment tout ce qu'il fallait après
l'ouverture des fenêtres on fait
vraiment des efforts évidemment on voit
bien que le xz kuti fait face un mur il
continue dans cette stratégie du tout
vaccinal avec un aveu jean castex qui
dit que oui ce sont les non vaccinés et
les personnes avec un schéma vaccinal
nom complet qui sont dans les services
de réanimation mais qu'est ce que ça
signifie aujourd'hui un schéma de
vaccination nom complet est ce que ces
deux doses tout simplement alors là la
promesse de la troisième dose olivier
ferrand nous la donne c'est un gros
boost 2 90% à d'immunité pendant
quelques temps et puis à la question est
la quatrième dose olivier vers ans avoue
ne pas savoir et travailler avec les
autorités israéliennes et les instances
internationales
donc sans doute la quatrième dose est à
attendre si on ne sort pas de cette
vague au micro et puis on sort sur les
peurs vagues dans la vague méga vague
super vague vague de delta avec 2
microns on est noyé finalement avec
encore une fois déjà jonction
contradictoires des mesures ubuesque et
puis toujours une seule stratégie
limiter les libertés et faire de la vie
des non vaccinés une impossibilité
c'est-à-dire rompre le pacte républicain
de liberté égalité fraternité et le
faire là et c'est là où c'est assez
pernicieux en disant que ces lois
scélérates sont des lois de la
république
eh bien non elles sont des lois
totalement scellera puisqu'elles sont
d'eloise prise dans un contexte de
d'urgence sanitaire de 2,2 alors on va
pas employer le terme de dictature
sanitaire mais on va on va dire que là
il ya une gestion totalement hors champ
or non démocratique puisque les
délibérations quasiment pas lieu ou sont
fait ultra rapidement sans le temps du
débat éthique ontologique et
démocratique pour simplement forcé les
français à se vacciner et dire que
cocorico la france est le pays le plus
vaccinée du monde mais pour quoi faire
si c'est pour ceux contaminés et
continue et d'attraper le coc vide et
puis comment faire confiance enfin à
jean castex lui qui nous disait que le
vaccin empêcher la contamination est
empêchée de disséminer le virus il ya de
ça quelques mois pourquoi aujourd'hui
alors qu'il nous dit que la troisième
dose protège de micron il faudrait le
croire comment peut-on encore croire ces
gens qui ont raconté tout et son
contraire pendant des mois parce qu'ils
ne savent pas plus que nous comment
faire face à cette crise du coc vite
donc voilà une conférence de presse ça
ne nous manquait pas et dire qu un
conseil de défense va encore avoir lieu
la semaine prochaine on repart dans le
ja kadima cronista aller et jacadi il
faut marcher à cloche-pied dans la rue
avec un masque et bien les préfets
ferons sorte que tous les français le
fasse sans quoi attention à l'amande
alors jean castex l'a happé un lors de
cette conférence de presse la
vaccination
n'empêche pas bien sûr de contracter le
virus mais empêche en tout cas selon lui
de développer des formes graves vous
avez entendu notre débat tout à l'heure
entre alex fille alexis poulain annoncé
vous entre gilbert collard et france 4 9
me gilbert collard disait que la rrq le
gouvernement pendant ces deux ans avait
parfois manqué de de pédagogie et de
prudence notamment au moment de ce genre
de dan on sait ce que c'est ça c'est un
sentiment vous vous partagez
mais tout est une mise en scène
d'opérette en fait depuis le début de
cette crise de la déclaration des
monnaies le maquereau en face à un
hôpital de campagne sur un supermarché
en disant nous sommes en guerre
jusqu'à ses conférences de presse
cryptée où il raconte n'importe quoi
avec des éléments de langage qui sortent
de la haute autorité de santé et puis
qui change tous les mois à peu près
après avec en plus maintenant
l'ignominie d'une politique du
bouc-émissaire faire peser toutes les
mesures sur les non vaccinés mais enfin
quand il fait à part ne pas se vacciner
et maintenant on a eu ce qui engorge
soi-disant les services de réanimation
mais les non vaccinés sont les doubles
vacciner d'hier que va-t-il se passer si
jamais la troisième dose n'est pas
suffisante le pass et vous savez combien
j'étais contre cette mesure dangereuse
pour la démocratie et qui rompait le
pacte républicain il ya maintenant le
pass est devenu un outil du quotidien il
ne devait pas être là pour empêcher
d'accéder à des activités du quotidien
maintenant si vous n'êtes pas vacciné
fini le cinéma fini le restaurant fini
le reste enfin on est en train de
rentrer dans un monde du contrôle total
c'est ce qu'on appelle la société de
vigilance emmanuel macron cette société
elle n'est pas souhaitable il faut le
dire est et pourquoi parce que ce n'est
pas aux français de surveiller les
autres français de les empêcher d'avoir
des droits qu'ils ont de fait la liberté
elle est inaliénable tout comme le droit
de disposer de son corps aujourd'hui ce
gouvernement par la contrainte par
l'extorsion vaccinale pousse les
français à se vacciner à multi doses
pour soi disant lutter contre des
variants qui
on ne connaît pas encore vont sans doute
arriver puisque ce qu vide maintenant on
est 5 quasiment sortis de la phase
pandémique c'est devenu une épidémie
saisonnière et ça ne va pas se finir et
d'ailleurs libérant le disait qu'
aujourd'hui chez les plus jeunes sont à
l'hôpital c'est les enfants avec la
bronchiolite ce ne sont pas les enfants
avec le co vides il y en a quelques-uns
et c'est à déplorer mais pourquoi
l'hôpital traque parce que les gens
comme jean castex comme olivier veyrat
ont cassé l'hôpital public depuis des
années allant même jusqu'à fermer des
lits pendant même la crise pandémique il
y a de cela deux ans donc on est
vraiment là avec des gens qui n'ont pas
conscience de ce qu'ils font qui ont
menti ou qui n'avaient pas les
connaissances nécessaires pour asséner
des vérités qui n'en étaient pas et qui
continue de faire ce cirque qui est une
mise en scène assez triste avec la
promesse qui n'est même plus celle d'une
vie d'après un vote d'une vie d'avant
mais qui est simplement de dire nous
luttons en réaction aux nouvelles vagues
alors voilà c'est vrai c'est un film qui
a trop duré comme un mauvais films de la
nouvelle vague et les acteurs que sont
jean castex et olivier ranson fatigué et
de sortir toujours les mêmes éléments de
langage je crois que les français aussi
ont totalement décrochés et quand je
parlais de mesures lisibles là on a
atteint encore une fois un paroxysme et
pourtant je pensais que c'était
impossible merci beaucoup alexis blanc
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir merci
d'avoir débriefer avec nous les annonces
ce soir de jean castex et d'olivier vers
en voilà c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de l'avoir suivi à prochain point
sur l'actualité c'est dans un peu plus
de trente minutes reste avec nous sur
arte france au total
[Musique]
certains font entendre leur voix pour
les autres c'est le silence qui parle
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi que dès qu'on
dit il n'y a pas d'alternative on s'en
doutait